foreign
companion uh last time I was here with
him
yeah I think we were wrestling over
there over there right there that's
where I put him in that ankle lock yeah
yeah you remember that I was really
relaxed I was relaxed and everyone was
like why are you trying to beat up the
old man
and they but then he said you got me I
switched you a little soon you did you
did okay
you were a little too high up yeah yeah
but I didn't sweep it I just kind of
went like that to say the point being
that Dylan Dennis is not a guy you want
to wrestle I remember I remember I
remember I wouldn't allow it yeah and he
that bastard that scumbag was like this
he was like try it because he does yeah
yeah that's a straight Jiu Jitsu yeah oh
no yeah I know he was like I dabble I'm
like I'm not letting you you'll get your
like but I don't think we're ever
talking about you you know I was never
gonna be like okay
this way and he pushes you back
um I feel probably the best I've found a
very long time yeah yeah cardio is
better than ever for sure really which
is more important to fight than being
[ __ ] big and strong yes
yeah
I box
yeah oh [ __ ] throwing hands chubby Road
Boston throwing hands yeah
um I don't have a trainer right now no
I'm just I'm just like it's just you
just hit a mess yeah
it's like he looks like you're smaller
brother
yeah that's me really someone said by
the facial hair no no
people have two eyes yeah
that guy looks more like wait a minute
hold on look at that guy they used to
like those two those two same structure
in the face those two oh that guy it
looks like him that that is Bradley yeah
yeah like my younger brother it's
Bradley light lights
we're gonna call you that now yeah
that's funny
it's time 50 less sugar yeah
[Music]
this is really the fighter and the kid
come on baby that's good yeah yeah I'm
ready whenever
clap Us in chin we're here it's a lot
more meaty in here it's a lot more
meaningful it's got a lot thicker in
here a lot stronger in here and a lot
more symmetrical I said it the kids got
a symmetrical delicate face
no all of a sudden my Beer's got a
delicate no no I'm saying you have what
I would call delicate speeches your nose
is on you have a long aqualine feminine
feature all right well you'd be you're a
very handsome man but you have a uh your
body's built for you know a lot of power
your face is rather sophisticated you
look like uh you look like a man you
look a little bit like a European
gentleman I said yeah
well you know you you could win uh Miss
Olympia because uh dude uh Miss uh
Universe well he looks if he was amazing
America or dude just one minute actually
he looks like you know what Bradley
looks like he looks like if he's just
from the neck up he looks like a
gentleman who rides horses
no no no not at all no he's not too much
he looks like grip from uh like a like a
more like uh [ __ ] boy rip from
Yellowstone hold on I mean you got like
a high boy High Beast is it just because
I cut my beard yes it is a handsome
bastard you're a very handsome guy but
your your beard is uh is well well quite
I think that my wife it's way better
than both of our facial hairs well hold
on to be fair I had a gym opening that's
why I got cut that like the night before
so it was really good yeah I just want
to like clean up you're getting
compliments you got the two earrings
they're diamond studs okay you don't see
I I can't get away with that nobody can
yeah and and Brennan I was usually a
good looking guy but his face is a
little swollen because of all the
substance abuse that he suffers from
alcohol and and so I looked at your face
and I went symmetrical and then I looked
at Ben and I went well we finished
things and that's okay so yeah then you
look at me and it's it's just things are
getting whiter and and smaller my head
is shrinking it needs more water I need
it I need a water your ears and nose not
shrinking though right ears and nose not
shrinking they grow my dick still hangs
well well we're talking about that
though my face all right yeah who
brought it there stay on the neck I have
to always bring it there oh he's got
he's always dead conversation but you
you uh got uh clean shaving haircut
because your new gym open day yes sir
Zoo culture where same gym uh same gym
we just had to upgrade it we need to get
a place with better parking more space
yeah like everything's brand new so we
have the old gym still it's a private
gym it's gonna be used for training and
the existing members the new space is in
Encino it's uh if you guys are
interested it's 16
571 Ventura Boulevard and that's what
off Balboa and uh humanhurst yeah yeah
that's right it's yeah Balboa is one of
the streets coming down to Ventura and
havenhurst so it's right it's pretty
much at havenhurst and Ventura well you
know who used to live off havenhurst
you're in good company who Michael
Jackson oh I did not know that really
but if I had thought about it remembered
like this house was there before like
the ranch or no no that's far from here
you're talking about the neverland match
his house was there though the house he
died and was over there oh really yeah
[ __ ] yeah that's where he lived like
during uh all this so legendary [ __ ]
over there there yeah dude you're in
good good I love it I love the area oh
encino's no hey Bradley I spent a day
with Brian Shaw yeah and uh I realized
how strong he was tell us how strong he
is when you guys were tussling and he
bought oh wait hold on a second let's
let's hold on this is there wasn't
enough room there
you talking about that video I'm just
saying Bradley I know but let me like I
got a video let me defend myself a
little bit he's strong as
[ __ ] videos Bradley starts tussling
with with the there that is Brian she's
got a massive strong he's one of the
strongest people in the world
he was the strongest all I'm saying is
the area that we're in you know the part
of zoo when you walk in right to the
left near the cardio equipment yeah it
was right there and I didn't have much
room to scatter yeah so I was just like
done well what happened was Brian
snatched him up like a school boy I mean
maybe not like a school boy like a like
a high like a high school like a
freshman really strong but that's the
strongest man in the world so you can
just stop defending yourself but no I
know I can't but it's weird though right
who wouldn't Brian shawl not if he gets
a hold of him yeah and I was trying to
get away and the second I couldn't it's
like isn't it weird when you can just I
mean you know it's weird yeah you
couldn't stop I mean the second he got
100 pounds right 400 45 pounds what are
we doing six eight I mean sorry six
eight what did I say sorry I'm tripping
he is a legit giant he can't sit and
Coach watch this now
okay
he's so God damn he's so big
no he's massive I mean the guy's like
400 plus pounds although you were I mean
you're not that you're not tiny dude I
mean you know that's
your arms are right there
yeah that's a good photo yeah yeah
he's a giant he's a legit Giant and and
competitive is all yeah he did yeah I do
actually that video he did
um I did say if it got a certain amount
of like likes and I think it did that I
wanted to actually try to wrestle him
like in like a real like a wrestling
match he's never wrestled he doesn't do
that stuff but he'll just like just [ __ ]
around I feel like that's probably a
recipe to get injured though yes I think
so yeah because he's so big because
let's say you shot it on a single leg
and he sprawled he's just so big he just
crashed you did he do any dead lifting
or squatting when you were there did he
do it yeah you're talking about this gym
yeah did he work out he yeah we worked
out we didn't we didn't do legs though
okay so no we just we did upper body
yeah but watching this guy bench press
like like five plates because his arms
are so long yeah it's like the craziest
[ __ ] it is I mean there's massive I
think he took 720 on his back and
squatted it 13 times in under a minute
he goes and he goes I think I could do
20. I could do it 20 times I was like 7
20 on your back 20 times nuts okay yeah
it is this the shark match is different
like obviously there's power lifters
levels like bodybuilders there's levels
like the strength game yeah but the
strong man [ __ ] at that side like
physical size of a human is just
different have you ever tried the Thomas
inch challenge I wonder how you guys
what is that I wish I had mine what is
that what's the Thomas so the Thomas
ends he he found out when he's playing
basketball that he was stronger than
most because there's this it's a it's a
dumbbell
and it's a bring up the Thomas yeah it's
really thick and nobody can grab it you
just can't pick it up yeah but he
pinched it and picked it up and the guy
said what you just did
10 million people one in 10 million
people cannot do one in you know uh 50
million he said and if you don't do
something with your strength it's a
travesty yeah on top only one person can
listen 100 years and he did it
who
oh that's Juju so who did they're all
trying to pick it up so you're trying to
but how heavy is the dumbbell wait
they're trying to pick up with what
dumbbells stayed on the ground oh that's
Pete refused to budge it's called the
inch dumbbell
so just picking this thing up yes just
picking it up Thomas okay I've never
tried it now now you're thinking I've
never heard of it I would love to try it
yes oh so it's just real thick yeah and
I guess you you need um you need uh 372
pounds yeah you need crazy thumbs up
is he able to do it I think he did it
one thousand pounds
I think he did this right oh yes he did
yeah but he did it when he was playing
basketball he didn't know what it was he
walked over and he goes what what is
this and he just picked it up
and the guy goes do you know what you
just did
why would they have that on a high
school gym so wait they didn't it was
that it was at some Fair it was like
some circus thing or some [ __ ] you know
like it was so the story was he did it
with zero practice yeah he just walked
this was like oh this yeah like bam bam
yeah and they were like wait a minute
that makes sense that sounds like
something so this is a 18 minute video
of people just failing up against the
thing out there
not that [ __ ] yeah please but apparently
it's a very important marker for how how
you can do it how strong you are oh it's
pure grip how strong you are because if
it's if there's only one in 50 million
there's a lot of strong guys I think it
shows how big your hand is yeah it
doesn't mean and how much thumb strength
you have yeah thumb strength
okay if we're thinking about 50 million
like eye gouging ability like every
single guy that tried to attempt that is
very strong yeah but but apparently like
it's a good marker for your strength
being off the charts why because you can
pinch so hard that apparently that's
that correlates your hand strength
correlates to your forearm correlates to
your body like yeah but like that Juju
that guy's strongest [ __ ] he couldn't do
it Juju but he's not he's not a strong
man he's he's strong but he's not
world-class yeah but but I don't know if
every every single strongman can lift
that no yeah I don't know but I don't
know if it's a good indicator of just
straight I think they probably could the
strongman like Thor and those guys could
probably do it
you know dude you're just not strong I'm
just not strong they're just levels to
every [ __ ] game and that's all it is
and all that matters is grip strength
wow apparently it doesn't matter it
doesn't make sense
I just said something deep yeah
to be fair I don't know what the [ __ ] a
Thomas inch wasn't I don't think anybody
does that's the problem we all do now
you just learned about a week
nobody strong and he goes you're all
[ __ ] weak
circuit training every single person
there's some of the strongest people I
know couldn't do it yeah I think it's
more I've never seen you're an [ __ ]
by the way now that I'm thinking about
this you just [ __ ] make us feel weak
dude
I know your kitchen is
a window there's a window in your house
and I know where it is I can get in
there every time like I love that about
you because you're so competitive and
I'll just [ __ ] with you and now you're
[ __ ] up and now you have to go do the
Thompson no I just think you're an
[ __ ] now yeah I'm with Brad I just
don't think you know what you're talking
about I mean it's more you just don't
know I've spoken here I'm poking you
just telling you man if you guys want to
get serious about your strength you
gotta buy a Thomas inch have it sent to
Bradley's gym please yeah actually I
would like one that's actually cool if
anybody can do it you might be able to
it's 170 pound dumbbells first of all I
mean yeah that's already pretty hard
stupid wait
so stupid
yeah because you know with regular
dumbbells
Thomas uh was it Thomas was it called
Thomas inch stupid right it's [ __ ]
stupid what do you mean bud you know
it's in it's a 170 pound dumbbell check
it out bro yeah with 170 pounds it's
your pinch strength how's your pinstring
I'm asking how your PIN strength is what
I care about is Pinterest that would
really matter I went the kid has pin
strength that's what I said it was
because the beard well I've seen you do
a lot of crazy physical things but then
I went this is what I said to myself I
went that is pinstriping but can he
pinch strength yeah in my mind I went I
bet he's got pin strength that's off the
charts and then I went like this I mean
it's not Brian Shaw's it's fair that's
fair Brandon can we take a break because
I like to watch fighting but I also like
to make money oh dude I have something
for you then because this weekend UFC
283 is here baby this Saturday there are
two titles on the line and one bout is
historic UFC match with figareto facing
Moreno Ram Moreno for the fourth time
check out draftking Sportsbook the
official sports betting partner of the
UFC new customers can bet just five
buckaroos and get 200 in free bets
instantly B yeah Jamal Hill Glover Tech
Sarah you get the fourth fight of brand
Moreno and figarito who you got buddy
I'm going Moreno only because I just
love him me too I love him and then what
about Jamal Hill Glover texture uh you
have to go with Clover just because it's
his last fight ever and I'm not betting
against clever It's Brazil be a
nightmare I love Jamal Hill Hits like a
Mack truck though I know we'll see how
it goes he's the slight favorite that
would make sense it's a good bet though
Robert grabs you yup you want more
excitement get in on the playoff action
of the NFL it's happened this weekend as
well download the app right now use code
fighter new customers bet again five
dollars on UFC 283 and get 200 in free
bets instantly that's code fighter this
Saturday at draftking Sportsbook the
official sports betting partner the UFC
minimum age eligibility restrictions
apply C show notes for details that's
fair so uh you and Steve will do it had
a yeah you guys kind of had a I'll have
to feel Brian and he don't know the
drama on this but you and Steve will do
our boys you guys had a falling out you
didn't get together for like a few
months yeah that happened that happened
yep you went down to Miami didn't visit
him didn't stay at his house hurt his
feelings yeah we talked and is it over a
hundred dollars yeah one of his best
friends of Steve will do it yeah really
famous cat they they were really close
friends and then over a hundred dollars
they didn't talk for how many months 100
it was like a month like a month that
was Brandon so it was it was it wasn't
as simple so basically it was because
there we were at a Ferrari World in
Dubai okay and we were coming to film
stuff and he had his guy in with the
camera and my guy was gonna come in with
the camera later and from what I
understood was I was paying for everyone
to come in
first and then uh I think steiny was
coming in with Jacob and and they were
like they were like I was paying for
them like preemptively or some [ __ ] and
then uh I got pissed not because of the
pain it was because Jacob was like
supposed to come in with the camera his
guy got in with the camera and then
Jacob shut up he's like I couldn't get
him with the camera Jacob's your guy
Jacob's my guy okay so I was just mad in
the moment that Jacob didn't get in
because he films your stuff because he
films my stuff and so I let that bother
me because I was like for me I was just
like this was this it was stupid to go
do it and not get any of the content
yeah you know because it was like I mean
there's literally one thing you could do
there which was actually dope as [ __ ] at
the end of the day too it was just a it
was in the moment it was it was dumb of
me to be even upset about that took it
on Steve I didn't really take it
honestly but he did take it that way and
I could see why he did but I was just
like I was like yo this is [ __ ]
[ __ ] like and I originally it was
like towards steiny to be like yo you
gotta [ __ ] pay for that because like
you guys now could Steve not share the
footage with you no he could but it was
just I mean the way it kind of like the
flow Works in workflow like people just
they you know that's kind of cumbersome
to get it and do all this you on your
own yeah it's easier that way but it was
I mean it was it was it was dumb of me
you know and he said you tried to shake
him down for the hundred dollars no
that's not true no no no no no that's
not true I did I was like I I said I
seemed like the guy had a threatened no
I'm not gonna [ __ ] actually threaten
Steve yeah no but it was it was a thing
where I was like that was pretty stupid
but then I was like oh they seem good
and then you tweeted out this recently
yes he had his big gym opening I
couldn't go yeah uh Steve will do it
didn't show up and he tweeted out
Steve's a fake I said Steve's a hoe
didn't show up to my gym in a gym
opening fake ass
yeah and it got a ton of Engagement but
but at the same time like
honestly it's kind of a joke I don't
really give a [ __ ] I did want him to be
there because like support would be nice
yeah man I've been to a ton of events
like you know I'm not there's no [ __ ] I
get out of showing up to these happy Dad
events I'm not an owner not coming on a
part of it like that and uh I show up
just because like Steve's always kind of
been there for me you know he's been
there for him and I just figured like yo
you know you would be there for this
because this is an important day Jim
openings big deal yeah
um and he didn't at the end of the day
it's like I'm not super mad I get it he
does a bunch of other [ __ ] as well I'm
sure I know he'll come back anyways and
I know we're actually in the funny thing
about it is that we had been talking
about opening a gym in Miami together a
zoo and so we're still working on that
but it was just like you know
Steve's just a super particular guy
likes to [ __ ] well is that you and uh
Andrew say yeah that's when we did the
Pod um when we went to Dubai and that's
you and him in front of his Bugatti yeah
yeah
and then a bunch of other things that I
posted this has Bula Dubai Mr uh Natty
the liver King where were you at on the
liver King stuff were you upset like
everybody else or were you kind of the
people who've been around the business
going yeah no [ __ ] yeah I know I knew it
well it's sunny funny like the people
doing things funny it's like that kind
of mindset relationship is just exactly
like that Brad smokes cigarettes and I
literally never smoke cigarettes I've
never smoked cigarettes
no he he's funny like dude's great solid
[ __ ] guy it was just those stupid
moments that smoke cigarettes yeah that
I I already love him they like oh he's
hilarious he's a genius just look at his
captioning goes this this year do things
that scare you do things that you know
you've been putting off stop waiting for
the right time there's no more right
time than now here's a 2023. brad smokes
cigarette yeah no no no no no [ __ ]
awesome no dude's hilarious dude he's
hilarious he's been reaching for the
salt what the [ __ ] yeah that's easy he's
so [ __ ] that's funny I can tell what
he's like just from that I love him no
he's a great round and I'm sure the fan
base takes it seriously yeah they don't
know the relationship you know it's kind
of it's always been this kind of like
serious not serious thing like a lot of
people don't know a lot of people like I
mean first for years yeah this was [ __ ]
for years I was a drug dealer in
everyone's eyes and it's like I'm not
actually a drug dealer I've never
actually been a drug dealer I get smoked
in the face on this thank you so much
did that what'd that do to your face
um thank you sir you're the best George
I got uh that girl's in great shape yeah
Sarah's dope real one
um look at that dude ABS let's go get at
me [ __ ]
not like in general but I'm just that
was towards you that was towards you
that's where your one inch challenge
yeah you [ __ ] [ __ ] dumbass anyways
no um
yeah you were no I just want to bring
that back again you were actually kind
of just like really mean dude I just not
I'm not being mean I'm just know what
gets you and I know you're competitive
and
and get you're like you're like that if
I if there's a challenge you're like
this you can't help yourself and I love
that effect of me I don't care I
literally if you brought in here I I'd
be like I don't care you would do it I
have to do it I love that about you dude
what are you putting in your coffee
and you're talking about my beard and my
[ __ ] earrings and [ __ ] I got a fairy
[ __ ] face you took a mocha in your
[ __ ] coffee
[ __ ] losers
yo that's funny man
I use spoons oh that's fine you were
sucking on it [ __ ] yeah probably okay
rub it on your shirt that's great I just
cleaned it
but uh back to with liver King yeah go
ahead I you know you've met him you I
thought he was a good dude solved person
yeah I kind of felt bad for him like
yeah you got away you know he was lying
but also to me it was like yeah dude
obviously he's on [ __ ] no yeah for sure
that's because how many people in the
fitness uh Fitness industry they're
selling supplements they're selling out
supplements and like yeah I use this
creatine like we've had Mr limpion and
he was like yeah thanks to this muscle
text like bro yeah I mean it's very
common obviously but I think he took it
to a different level because you know
when he did that circuit and and then
and I don't want to I'm not trying to
disrespect Brian or liver King and I
think like I said I I say there's a lot
of other things that he's talked about
that are like actually beneficial to a
lot of people yeah
um so I said Joe overall is good yeah
but at the same time like go on that
circuit and say like I'm Natty I'm Natty
and like vehemently deny the whole thing
like if you want to just where it gets
done avoid a topic ignore it like the
rock or be like hey I don't want to go
into this topic yeah like they're wrong
there's no rocks on gear like for him to
say he's on a Gear is insane he said he
tried it once come on
my thing is that you're you you have to
know and do that visible and you're
you're gonna get found out it's what the
internet's here for which I actually
appreciate about the internet but his
his thing but his thing was he was like
it just became this Beast I was like oh
[ __ ] I gotta ride with this like his
goal was to come out of it but he's like
he just got out of hand well yeah but
that's the thing is like but he got it
out of hand you know like uh it's he you
he said no so many times it's almost
like the Michael Hearn thing like
Michael hearn's been saying he's naughty
since the beginning and it's like but
are you though yeah like I mean he's
like did he look any better he looks
better he's [ __ ] incredible and this
is this is what it is because I'm like
this is the yeah it's the most important
thing about though this stuff oh that
guy yeah he was like oh come on yeah
he's naughty his whole life we got on
the left side yeah Rich Piana rip to a
legend yeah he was very open about his
usage and all this [ __ ] well yeah you
have to be but but this guy on the right
you know he's he lied you know lied
about it for so long and I'm not saying
he's a bad guy do you get found out no
there's no there's no finding out of him
right because he's I don't know he's not
we'll look into his emails yeah but it's
here's the thing with this guys no
matter what I just want this is the
thing with steroids that trip me out
people think that it's because and this
is why people get this whole like
detailed thing around steroids they
don't talk about it is because they go
people go They're gonna take away your
hard work of doing that I agree and I
got to say this and everyone listen
needs to know this you can't take
steroids and just look like that I could
never take stories and look like that no
like I'm telling you there are people no
[ __ ] no I'm saying that it's a
combination of really hard work very
specific work and a lifetime of work the
most of it's hard work and like to get
to that level in the discipline it's
also a lot of genetics it's not just
steroids yes genetics yeah facts but
it's also like people want to shoot on
Barry Bonds like hey you do all those
try to hit a baseball yeah I can't even
touch it yeah I can't touch that [ __ ] no
so it's with him I mean come on yeah
it's going to enhance you it's going to
make the things happen faster that would
have already happened like if you put an
effort in energy but but yeah man I just
think people get so caught up in like oh
they they want to take it away and I
think that's why these people are afraid
of just specifically talking about it
but it's like it's like taboo then it's
a little more out there I just don't
talk about but it's the ones who go no
I'm Natty I'm Natty I'm Natty I'm not
even they're vehement about it and then
they're selling products that's when it
becomes like yo you're telling people
you're Natty and then you're saying go
buy this that's when it gets dicey can
you look at somebody like that and know
what they're on
no you can never really know what's
going on tough no yeah you're probably
gonna know there's probably some test
based yeah and then you know depending
on how dry they are who maybe they're
running some [ __ ] oral or something
that's more like removing of estrogen
yeah we're trying to answer both those
like not going to convert into estrogen
so it's like they're going to be a
little drier than someone who just takes
like higher androgens with you know with
the conversion as well so it's like
because anytime you increase
testosterone your estrogen kind of
balances so it's like if you increase it
and you're not removing it like you can
get like the little water like your more
watery face what are what are peptides
can you talk because I know they're
coming out with different kinds of
peptides yeah peptide is like a like a
like amino acid it's like it's like a
but it's a great human growth naturally
or something or there's a bunch of
different types of other types so I'd be
like saying this win straw create human
like they're all they're all different
there's like peptides for like
inflammation for growth hormone release
everything really you know there's
different steroids for everything yeah
yeah it's it I don't know I don't know
enough about specifically about peptides
I've never actually done them I've done
back in the day I've done melanitan
which is like to tan your skin when I
was like when I was doing competitions
when I was like 20 23. it's like a shot
you take to get darker yeah it's like uh
it's like you're trying to get that
chocolate body well yeah it's like you
want it to be Tanner because you show up
on stage you have a nicer 10 you get a
better presentation yeah
um that's only peptide I ever took did
it make you darker yeah it worked but so
the thing about it is like it makes your
moles darker faster and then your skin
darker so like you might have like moles
that look really dark and I just got
sketch I was like this is going to be
skin cancer or some [ __ ] I really want
to deal with it and also like and also
too does your face get black too all
your all your skin it doesn't get black
it's just like you get tanner like where
if you went out to the Sun and tan it
just makes it happen faster I don't know
because it affects melanin or something
oh and I'm listening right now don't be
a surprise it's called Melania tan but
anyways yeah it also gives you like uh
[ __ ]
erections one it makes you Tanner so so
if you take turn yeah so if you take too
much of it it makes you it doesn't make
you tan like this it'll make you tan
over time you take it over time but if
you take too much like in one injection
like you could you hard dick and upset
stomach really I swear to God can now
can you take so much you turn black I
don't think it works like that I think
it's what you're gonna like your
questions I like where you're going just
see it well I want to know what they're
going to be able to do and like in 20
years it's gonna be very interesting to
see what kind of oh my God man you know
I feel like it's exciting well I don't
know where we who was I talking to about
hair loss and [ __ ] but like probably me
probably you yeah you two should
probably talk about it yeah anyways but
uh you know it's a story from your hair
oh I have totally am back here it's okay
anyways brainstorm something I'm gonna
figure out but my point what I was
talking about was I think they're gonna
figure out like all that kind of [ __ ] oh
yeah like to like where they're just
like you don't have that anymore for
sure but then the world gets weird think
about that everyone's gonna be perfect
there's nothing so so I I had dinner
with a guy at UCLA a scientist
um who is specifically about hair loss
well he works in um Gene editing and all
this stuff like he's the head of the
department that does at the Forefront of
all this new medical science uh wow this
house is good I know it is so that's
black coffee regular yeah that's a
village that's a Phil's Coffee so
um he was telling me about I don't even
know if I can even say it but they they
have cures for crazy diseases like
sickle cell anemia and stuff the problem
is
that it's a million dollars dose right
now so they do have the technology to do
crazy [ __ ] like so they've done a lot of
work on muscle wasting disease like for
ALS or for uh Cushing's Disease all
these things the New Frontier of
manipulating your myostatin and things
like that is [ __ ] amazing bro so
steroids are going to be like that old
school [ __ ] now you're gonna be able
to take something in about 10 20. it's
like HGH changed the game because
remember like the Arnold days like they
look they didn't look like so much
freakish and then yeah HH came along and
then you just get these it's also
insulin yeah I think HH and insulin's
were the two that changed it just made
them unrealistically they got the
cartellis right insulin power does
insulin and growth yeah I'd say mostly
feels like mostly related to insulin
just like excessive growth hormone use
it just you can't decide what it's going
to grow it grows everything your organs
your stomach your heart people just
started overdoing [ __ ] because they were
just there's some people who just so
genetically gifted like the Rodney
Coleman that's what it was that guy was
so like free he just freakish and
responsive to this stuff that everyone
else to even play in the same category
was like oh [ __ ] we got to do all this
then we got weird then it got very weird
yeah and I feel like it's kind of coming
back down now like people like I mean
it's not as popular that's what's weird
it was never as popular like it got to
this freak level because like people
were looking just for the freak aspect
of it but then like no one really wanted
to look like that unless you were you
were a hardcore I want to be that
bodybuilder you know so then the fans if
you start losing fans because people
aren't like well I like the freakness of
it but I don't actually want to look
like that eventually people just care
less and less yeah and bodybuilding now
the vacuum stomach came back this gets
back coming back yeah maybe because of
classic physique bodybuilding itself not
so much but Arnold came out recently was
saying that he thinks classic should be
just [ __ ] bodybuilding yes and I
agree I think like I I can't it's it's
tough because like I'm not saying all
those other guys what they're doing is
not worthwhile or validated I just think
like a lot of people more people would
be like wow this is the sport I want to
go towards as a whole if it was like
more Arnold area yeah I agree Arnold era
and like you know the classic level now
where was in such a look like you look
at Ronnie Coleman those Jay colors back
in the day you're like
and I can't take away from this at all
like the work ethic everything it took
to get there is [ __ ] insane like to
be able to be even willing to do what it
takes to get there is is incredible
Ronnie Coleman paid the price now though
I mean yeah
he's such a nice guy man yeah have you
had him on no should have him on he's
[ __ ] dope too Jack the city yeah I
mean he he changed bodybuilding he
changed it I watched that documentary on
him he's just different yeah
he would just lift so much heavier than
yeah he was different bro like a hundred
percent just well if you ever see
pictures of him before he was even when
it was natural it's astonishing yeah
he's definitely and that's the thing too
we talk about natural not natural this
kind of [ __ ] in the fitness industry
he's an example of someone who looked
like a absolute person who was abusing
steroids yes what wasn't using steroids
agree well you can see this in the NFL
I'm sorry some of these young guys
they're in college and they're such
freaks and but yeah I don't think
they're taking so I I think I think he
was natural here actually where where
that one on the left that's that one on
the left which is insane that's just
genetically I was 91. nuts yeah I think
he was
which is [ __ ] wild and then then if
you're a young kid and let's say you're
into fitness back then I mean it's just
not attainable like you're like oh [ __ ]
this but to your point with Arnold
you're like now granted you don't have
his genetic guess but you're like all
right I can see that
like even you're talking about the idea
of even wanting to be at that level
right yeah yeah like to even yeah to get
into it like when it was those big boys
like Jay Cutler and Ronnie people like
no well I meant bro I'm gonna tell you
the truth when I got into training in
general that Ronnie J that's what I
wanted originally really that's what I
was trying to do I was set up jump off
the train
um drink HGH hell no so it was when uh
to be honest I got I just got you know
out of the competition industry because
I was so like demotivated because of
what had happened to me within it like
politics yes and in relationship to my
popularity outside of it so I was in it
being like Oh I want to I wanted I was
like I was a kid 18 19 20 years old I
was like I'm gonna be a [ __ ]
bodybuilder
muscular always you grew up like no you
weren't I was skinny but once I started
once I started really training I was
like oh no I I'm getting big like it
happened pretty fast when you say skinny
like skinny yeah bro I was like I was
like 153 what 5 11 when 16 yeah 16 third
grade yeah and once you started filling
out though that was like one two five
six seven yeah yeah yeah but yeah I was
I think uh the I think I was like uh 17
18. I must have been two
Thirty
yeah that's me six six just six Sixteen
on the left
yeah
you look like a school shooter yeah
that's funny you know I was just getting
to puberty on that one look at that
right there
that's good how old were you in those
gym shorts uh that's 14. the gym the
shorts in the middle that's the first
competitions I do I won that I won the
overall that was a body right there that
was too scared 22 23 maybe so this is
around the time when I started this I I
got like first and overall and then I
went to a bigger show and it's called
the usas and I went there and at the
time they only gave out one pro card
I'll never forget this and um I'm up
there and like everyone's like you're
gonna win you're gonna win and then I I
get second and every show after that
they give out two pro cards and I
remember being like what the that this
show right here actually this is a show
that I got second and uh everyone was
like you got rob you got I remember
because back Facebook was what everyone
was using holy [ __ ] look at that 525
likes that's all that [ __ ] is
um you're good back there anyways so I'm
on stage and I remember they called the
guy and I called everyone else and then
they it's like between me and him first
and second and I call him and I'm like
hmm and then
you know you have the conversations
where everyone's like you got robbed you
got Robin you get all these messages on
Facebook not gonna help and then I talk
to the people and then you start to
realize oh you know this person got this
extra kind of push because that person
is friends with the promoter that his
trainer at the time it was a woman who
was training it was just I'll never
forget this guy's name Nick guard what's
his name he's the guy who won it what's
up yeah he was training under
um [ __ ] I forgot her name but she was a
trainer who was very closely connected
to the show promoter there you go so
then it's like oh this new class we're
gonna bring these exactly so I remember
being like yo I hate this [ __ ] and then
I didn't like it and then it bothered me
because that was when I had no clout no
popularity like social media was just
kind of still doing that and then it
kept doing that and this is why I got
out of the bodybuilding space where I
was like [ __ ] this [ __ ] and I'm just
going to keep doing the internet was
because
I went to a show then later on where the
guy was telling me to come to his show
his name is Lee Thompson part of the NPC
same Federation Lee Thompson here out of
Texas he said come do my show like
because I started getting popular and he
wanted me to promote the fact that I'm
coming to the show right and he
literally was telling me like you'll win
come do my show oh [ __ ] you're like I'm
not even in shape yeah no no yeah you're
weird yeah like I like I could show up
and win yeah but for someone to say come
to my show you'll win yeah you're like
show promoter I'm like oh this is what
happened to me the first time and I felt
really like [ __ ] right yeah so I come
to a show and before I even walk on
stage he's like number one
let's see it's like his show and I'm
like I'm like it's cool and like I
didn't look bad you know and I could
have won the show but knowing that it's
going to be what I think it's going to
be based on all these other
circumstances maybe like this shit's
lame yeah that sucks but you're
different than I feel like a lot of the
bodybuilders and you when you look at
you there at 22. like I I would never
think that you're you're very [ __ ]
strong I mean we're joking around about
Brian Shaw but as far as like a guy who
bodybuilds you're strongest yeah I was
always weirdly strong yeah yeah like
like why are you anyone think Bradley's
not strong no but I'm saying that like
it's not just bodybuilding it's like
when you look at him there and you're
saying you were Skinny It's funny
because I would look at you there at 16
or even there and I'd go I would think
good body bodybuilder but I wouldn't
think you had that weird crazy strength
yeah that that sure as [ __ ] not when
you're 12 not school shooter but even
there when he's 22.
Jesus Christ yeah
that was terrible hey man take it easy
bro we all done okay yeah fair I don't
know [ __ ] let me look at them I like an
idiot I don't trust that kid yeah but I
was really strong then too look at that
you were strong then too yeah I was
always had like that weird wiry strength
I don't know is it tendons or muscles or
both well it's got to be built tendon
strength hat is hugely related to it
like being able to move weight like that
it's hugely related to like muscular
strength yes because without the tennis
strength you don't have the musculus
right but if you if you're getting the
bodybuilding now this is who's your
North Star you know what I'm saying like
if you're you're a kid right now right
now Chris Bumstead who Chris said yeah
yeah go to that chin yeah he's he's he
he's there he's the new and he's Young
by the way he's 27 yeah he looks every
bit of 45 but he's 27. no these just go
with Stage photo
like these and he is is he natural
bodybuilding or no hey I know that's not
what I meant I mean is he is he uh
physique he's classic physique he's
classic he's not was that mustaches
[ __ ] class yeah he brought that back
um but yeah this is this is the guy so
he's the guy the kids look up to it 100
this is the guy for for her now he's not
like Ronnie Coleman freakishly Jay
Cutler freakishly big he's just a and
that's what they're saying so that's
that's what when Arnold's talking about
bringing it back to
they're saying yeah that's Chris they're
saying that this is the guy they should
be like this
and and he won what uh well he looked
he's won four yeah he looks like Arnold
back in the day yeah exactly yeah that's
the new thing 14 million followers and
he's the guy yeah yeah
damn he's just definitely Maddie right
is he he is he uh he looks short is he
is he tall he's he's a little he's a
little shorter than I am let me look at
the photos to your face though well
there well there he's depleted though
yeah yeah this is like yeah water all
that kind of [ __ ] God that doesn't look
good there's no water in his face God
damn look at his wheels though dude I'd
wear a mask
I'd wear a mask I mean you know that's
him there yeah boy that's me
you're not that different dude you're
not that different but it doesn't look
like him his face looks so different hey
I love bread but it all look like that I
don't look like that I like that no no
no that's like he's died
maybe yeah see look how skinny his neck
is there see what's wrong yeah don't
disrespect my neck
is he Canadian or is that just a
Canadian tattoo no he's Canadian oh wow
yeah he's from Good Old Canadia no he
just got a Canadian tattoo I'm gonna
imagine yeah I'm from Texas
yeah
oh a bunch of tattoos where I'm from a
ton of people have it got a buffalo
tattoo I play for the bills though right
you guys are so stupid so funny dude he
is jacked I'm not a Hurley guy yeah
Chris bumps head bro yeah I know even
I've heard of him I know I'm not
addicted to dudes right what no I don't
care what do you mean I'm not addicted
to dudes either I don't know what you're
talking all Brian does is search Tick
Tock I'm like dude look how freakishly I
was looking up Herschel Walker's son
he's got the best skin I've ever seen in
my life the gay kid yeah I was looking
him up going I wonder if there are any
shirtless pictures
what guys I'm straight but I'm saying oh
You Gotta Give It Up to a kid's skin
young man I was doing a podcast and he
came up you were talking about his
[ __ ] skin look at his skin he's a
smart kid dude I'm sorry
Bradley I'm straight okay dude I get it
you don't have to tell me okay but
you're the one saying it I didn't say it
that's the guess thing you've ever done
all right how old is each and is this
legal I don't know hey bro he's in his
20s I mean bro you're looking at him
he's 23 years old serial killer no I'm
the bad guy he's like I want to wear his
skin like what the [ __ ] no nobody in the
history of everybody I have to look
through this guy's profile and check out
his skin yeah
but that is
a filter you son's a [ __ ]
you guys are haters you've got some
haters you straight haters straight
haters for 100 that was nice I'm getting
lost Jesus Christ bro give it up for his
facial features propose that we charge
liberal family okay
man here's my thing Angel Crown being
gay and so this the gayest thing you've
ever done yeah yeah you search this
young man's profile what to look at his
skin I'm not in a [ __ ] corner a law
here I was just bringing up the fact
that Ryan's like yes what
why would you say it's gay the tight
leather coach the greatest band honestly
it is just the pants straight up dude
well the stance ain't helping I guess he
doesn't I guess he doesn't talk to his
father oh no she went bad on his dad oh
he went bad on his dad during the
election That's What Causes That
his dad well
I want to see what your PIN strength is
yeah that's now it's starting to make
sense you want to know the pinstrade now
it's making sense Jesus
somebody said somebody said butt sex I
was doing improv on my show and somebody
goes butt sex and they wanted me to
improvise and I go like this I'm in Fort
Wayne Indiana and I go
I mean I had a dream that I was gay
I got I had butt sex and I was the
receiver and Lexus Indiana yeah do you
think people laughed everybody was like
there was this too good there was that
that two people were like oh it's a
little gay there's a line like I could
see dude it's gone like fans am I going
I got it this is weird
I had to backtrack there's a line where
it's fun but bro that shit's hilarious I
know I was like no it was a dream guys I
woke up and I was like I was like
frowning what was the what was the punch
line on that one I don't remember what
the punchline is
yeah oh God this is great okay well I
learned that guy's the face of
bodybuilding though I've never heard of
him yeah you know what I believe in my
silicon dude in my heart yeah Brandon
was just a little drunk and had a little
ketamine or one of those love drugs
poppers and the guy was super good
looking like him like a commercial walk
or something and he was like and Brendan
was just like feeling great no her
stronger sounded too feminine
look at that comment look at that
comment Larry said first slide could
pass for Bradley Martian if your eyes
got seven I've taken a photo exactly
like this before
go to my Instagram daddy Jack go to my
Instagram wait don't scroll way down
scroll way down and how much money do
you think he's making Bradley a year ah
probably a Time 14 million followers is
probably doing the damn thing depends it
depends how he's positioned himself but
you know you never know some people get
taken advantage of yeah you're right so
you're going yeah keep going yeah go
down to 98. oh yeah all right we're just
here for [ __ ] seven hours yeah no
keep going man
2001. it's great yeah somewhere here
maybe it was up [ __ ] no keep going keep
going no Bradley do you feel weird that
Brian scours your Instagram and jacks
off yeah no it's kind of sick
I have a boner right now but I'm just
saying look at that there it is yeah
that was good there you go
similar both juicy now go back tune for
a second go back up uh no yeah go see
Bradley mine right there look at the
price look at the time oh this with the
touch so good so I went to look at you
same job dude
all boys high school there you go there
you go where was that in San Francisco
okay
yeah and
and you're straight guy right
yeah no I know yeah oh boys how's that
gay men like you probably yeah you get
some looks um if you're a good-looking
dude though gay men and women are gonna
like you right yeah no but I feel like
he's like he's every gay man's dream
no only if they like big bears right
yeah but he's not just a bear he's all
shredded up and [ __ ] he's awesome yeah I
don't know yeah I don't know he's
proportioned but high school high school
all boys high school it was it was good
though like it wasn't what you think it
you know it's not like no it's you well
what do you thinking what do you think
we're thinking well no I mean if you're
saying San Francisco all boys high
school we're making all these jokes okay
Bradley I said nothing I mean listen you
were saying a lot earlier but no no I'll
tell you what you can get a little gay
brother you can be open open about this
even Arnold's allude to this
yeah you want that protein spots
somebody's got to rub you down
somebody's got to rub you down in oil
You're Gonna Miss spots no no I'm not
talking about that he's talking about
some other [ __ ] Arnold like done some
like you know he's talked about it like
even Sebastian did some weird [ __ ] back
in the day what do you mean you know you
sold a pair of underwear
oh okay when you were bro like that he's
a broke kid and then weeder came I
didn't do anything like beyond that but
I sold some underwear yeah that's fine
oh well I have a story about that about
my soul no no hold on you you hold on
you so uh it was a used pair of
underwear and just someone bought it
someone is going to come back in the day
when you saw those uh pictures the
competition ones someone was like you
know my Instagram's kind of growing
they'd be like so I want to buy your
underwear I just sell them for 800 a
pair
see now that's awesome right I [ __ ]
approve Tim 800 I improved and I was
broke as [ __ ] yes I sold four pairs
that's great yeah yeah but back in the
day like a lot of bodybuilders did that
yeah like Arnold talked about it like
you had some weird [ __ ] but you know
when you say weird [ __ ] like like as
straight guys whenever I hear for real
like I hear like uh as a half straight
man yeah like there you go weird [ __ ]
would be okay you can say selling your
underwear
but weird [ __ ] would be like watch like
if I'm talking to you and I was like
yeah I mean some guys have to do that
suck the guy off in college we'd all go
wait wait hold on we gotta stop what did
you say yeah no I've never done that no
that's yeah that's not a phase that's
something's going on that bad yeah yeah
like like so I I knew it because I'm
saying like yeah I don't know man I knew
a guy was a trainer and he was a stud
and he dated women and he was like just
a a man a man's man rough guy handsome
guy this is 25 years ago good thing
listen
today is over the top yes why are you
really just sick really yeah are you
homophobic not in any fast then why are
you getting all upset because you're too
gay today okay keep going a little too
old keep going all right now listen so I
I I knew him for a while and he trained
me for a while and then the story's
getting good dude it's getting good and
and uh and and then my the these two
gals okay there's some women involved
that owned uh that whose parents owned a
restaurant that he used to frequent that
I knew because I had something to do
with one of them came to me and said do
you know about so and so and I said what
she said well we got our hands on a porn
and it was a an all-male porn and your
boy was banging all the guys oh and I
was like wow that's very interesting to
me he needed the money now selling your
underwear for money and banging guys for
money there's a difference here those
are two completely different yes because
how bad you want a card how bad you want
now I had a guy when I when I was
fighting you'll see this guy I don't
want it that bad this guy was in bot
this guy was in bodybuilding and he
would make the he was known as like the
meal guy so he'd make all the meals for
the fighters and became my buddy
whatever and then one of his friends DM
me back in the day it was like hey man
do you know what he does outside inside
the meal business I'm like yeah
bodybuilding he's like type in I'm not
gonna say his name we can do it off here
because type this into the search bar
and just type in porno I was like all
right you typed it
bro there's gay porn then there was this
I mean just like multiple digits
yeah when you got two dicks man uh yeah
yeah I was like oh man and then and then
my and then my brothers get the meals
too and I go I don't care do you do
whatever he wants and then we got our
meals and had like white sauce over the
top and he goes I can't eat this I feel
sick I can't eat this I go I can't
either we have to we have to stung in
the meals just because you know it's
like it is what it is one video is just
elbow dating somebody's ass
Teriyaki you know it's like I don't want
this there are some extremes that go on
yeah Bradley I apologize you had to come
on this podcast yeah no it's good I'm
glad change the subject no this is great
but you opened a new gym for God's sake
yes can we talk about that go ahead
let's talk about it God I'm excited but
just be clear even Arnold said he did
some weird stuff back what did he say he
did because I don't know I forget with
weed or who said he did some words like
some pictures they're all struggling
some pictures you know pictures some you
know my final here I don't know
interesting when he said that yeah in
his book okay I think I might have made
that up you might have made that up no
I'm pretty sure he did though but the
special Sloane's definitely go to the
Instagram the Instagram yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah I'll get some good some
fun stuff there I was telling you
because Fox News did a thing on you
and uh they did a thing on you because
Ryan Garcia came to opening your gym
yeah but Fox News Tucker Carlson would
be all over it too because you're one of
the only businesses that in California
that during lockdowns refused to lock
down you battled the city you won yeah
and now the business is flourishing
massive like how your team don't reach
out to Fox like hey check this story out
you know you're on the right page right
now okay yeah I I would love that man
I'd love I'd love to I mean I don't know
what questions they would ask but yeah
they're just like what what did you do
with the city because remember how
stressful it was because I was working
at your gym and it's like every day like
what's going on they would show up
remember the they would show up they'd
shut things down like turning lights off
shut the AC off during the middle of the
summer and then his landlord hated him
so we couldn't Park so we had to park
like a mile away and walk in and you
just fall through it yeah the lighting
up there is awesome the gym is beautiful
yeah we got that piece in the middle
over the turf go up a little bit that's
right there yeah wow um I mean you
advertise Steve will do it was going to
be there yeah guys damn what a gym so
yeah so yeah we had all these people but
yeah man I mean the as far as that City
thing you know like I talked about this
a few times the most frustrating part
was just that like
because it was it was it was so bad you
know to they were like it's so bad what
you're doing everyone's so and then you
get to the point where
they dismiss something because it's like
there's not really anything there to
prove that is actually bad from the
space so he'd have to go to court all
the time I got to get stressed out yeah
City because you mean too by the city
for staying opening staying open and so
you have to keep doing it but then the
lawyers they're like they really have me
I like to stand up like they're they
can't so when the court would would say
you have to shut down what would you say
during the pandemic
no so I did go into court once and the
guy was like reiterating what the city
was saying and I just was like okay I
hear you but I wasn't like okay I'm
gonna go do this you know right so there
wasn't a directive the city was saying
what you cannot be open yeah it was like
you're a non-essential business yeah and
you can't be open which you know in the
same I I in my opinion I believe it is
yeah and and to say a business is not
essential is also an interesting thing
just that's a whole nother conversation
because it's like how are we determining
that who are they to say someone's
livelihood is essential to them right so
it's like you end someone's entire like
I could have spent 30 years to build
that gym like of my life 30 years to
build income to be able to buy that and
to say I had no social media I had no
Outreach no way to make money outside of
the gym and they say you know what
that's cool you spent your life to
create this it's done now and it
happened to so many people exactly so
that's the thing that got me frustrated
about that whole like essential versus
non-essential but yeah I would go in
there and they'd be like supposed to
shut it down I'd be like and then I come
back and they would just keep sending
people to come to like tell me hey
you're supposed to be shut down and they
just keep sending me like
um fines and they just piled up and they
eventually were like yeah we're gonna
let it go you just kept fighting it yeah
because I I think what are you going to
take that to trial and people are going
to be like in my mind I go okay you're
telling me then all these other things
are okay to be open Costco down the
street all these other places are fine
Mass amounts of people in there I'm
asking them every time like what about
the airports massive amounts of people
in there in the same time all this other
shit's okayed and okay to be open
but this is just not good and it's like
we we know now how important the gym is
working out eating right in my health
everything for coven by the way exactly
to combat that right and and my problem
with it was really like it was just a
displacement of like where it matters
versus when it doesn't matter it's just
a complete weird irrationalization where
it was like it's okay here not okay here
it's okay at the airport and I would
tell them like well can you explain to
me why this is okay here well we don't
deal with that that's Federal
jurisdiction we're just public officials
we work in like the public sector not
the federal sector I'm like so kova
doesn't spread in the federal sector as
I was saying well we can't answer that
question it's like you there's no
democracy so you could have said what
went on they just kind of faded away
yeah started to come out and they're
like oh okay but and then even before
the science comes out if we know that
they knew right away that it affected
our respiratory system like our heart
and our cardiovascular system right so
it's like why would we go okay stay home
and hide inside and don't do you know do
don't do anything because you should be
afraid and instead of like pursuing like
bettering that part of your body did you
see what Bill Maher and you sent this to
me and I'm so glad you did Bill Maher
took a look at what happened thanks
buddy Bill Maher took a look at wow this
is we're going back to that again well
no no this is my sponsor I'm going to be
bodybuilding that's all and you got some
strong hands
his hands roam man and I want to file a
format oh you want to talk to HR I'm
right here oh go ahead yeah I'm HR it's
so hot uh but Bill Maher uh basically
said that people were everything went up
domestic violence uh depression
everything kids were kids were like
the worst acts
accidents were up because people were
nuts they were just going nuts well this
is the thing it's like that that was the
thing the the irrational picking of
where it matters where it didn't matter
so it's like we're going to focus on
this thing yes this is a problem I'm not
saying it's not a problem but [ __ ]
suicide [ __ ] all this mental health
stuff [ __ ] everything all the other
repercussions that came along with
stuffing people inside for [ __ ] two
years [ __ ] all of them we have to learn
from it and I think the next time we
have a pandemic we have to just we have
to not have this overreaction and that's
that's the dude I got a ticket I was
riding my bike in the middle of the
Santa Monica Nobody's around two two
troop like uh uh Park Rangers on trucks
like Fast and Furious give me a ticket
during that time yeah I was like there's
nobody around he's like we're so sorry
one guy goes I'm actually a thick boy
man I'm I'm sorry I follow your stuff I
go then where do you're not giving me
take your regulars we have to so
literally we have you don't have to I'm
gonna tell me you don't have to well if
they're wearing cameras they do now oh
it's still then I was like do you know
this isn't gonna stop the camera's only
brought up when something had an
incident happens it's like a camera
doesn't make a cop or an official have
to do something you just want to [ __ ]
do it it was just such an insane time it
wasn't nothing no it's just it was
frustrating man like the I don't know
but thank God that's how I found a gym
because uh my boy Chappelle Lacey was
like dude this is because I was like man
I need to work out there's nowhere to
[ __ ] go I'm sick working at home
riding my bike she feels like dude this
is Jim I see on Instagram all the time
they're open I'm like really where's it
at send me the address I'm like dude
that's like a mile from my house yeah
he's like let's go check it out I walked
in there then you and I were like the
Batman meme yeah you right away or buddy
yeah exactly and that's the thing that
the so you said about Jim's not being
open this is the frustrating part of it
too that was another thing that I don't
think people really understand I've
explained it a few times but I'll say it
again during the same exact time it was
like I said the mistreatment of like
where it's okay versus where it's not
not just like business-wise gym wise
because I was on social media with such
a large Following being like look at me
in the gym they were running for me so
imagine there's a gym up the street
literally two minutes is the gym down
the street two minutes how many counts
do you think I had not listening to what
they said which is like being open in
the same exact time frame these other
two gyms doing the same exact thing one
of those gyms was owned by a larger
Corporation crunch but it was a smaller
version right were they allowed to be
open no no one was allowed to be but
they didn't get any they didn't give
them any attention no so imagine this so
look ask me how many how many non-uh
compliances do you think I had to their
rule how many
how many do you think okay I had
I think it was 66 67 or something like
that and how many do you think the other
two gyms had opened the same exact time
one
and and eight Jesus so it's like and I'm
talking about these gyms not only are
open for being an entrepreneur and I and
I'm saying like it's much for being a
handsome good looking it's not even
entrepreneur it's it's having a platform
that's right yep because they go because
you're going against the the agenda yeah
but so it's like you're gonna drive past
the other gym that you know is just as
open as mine we're gonna go to that guy
and say Here's your phone and we had I
had a good buddy who you know powerful
dude who was like I was a good what do
you think of Bradley isn't it crazy he's
[ __ ] it fighting the city he's [ __ ]
I'm like you think he's like oh yeah he
told me you know I was like what yeah he
told you your face yeah Joe told me that
in personally one of the UFC events oh
yeah because I don't I was like Hey
Brad's my boy look at a dude fighting
he's like dude he's [ __ ] and he saw
him in person he told he tells Rogan to
his face you're [ __ ] yeah he was like
dude it's not gonna be good I was like
and I got kind of worried yeah I was
like you think yeah I got kind of I was
like [ __ ] if Joe said enough I was like
I'm gonna tell him to shut down Joe will
catastrophize like Joe's always been
scary that's when I got scared for you
when Rogan was like he's [ __ ] like
really yeah George look at you and be
like hey hey I remember he was like you
live in Venice you're gonna die okay
he'll just he'll just call he'll look at
the worst case scenario yeah so I did
get scared after that and I was like
[ __ ] are you sure yeah he knows funny I
think he told him what he thought it he
told me um he he told me actually in
person he said he would have me on the
show if I got [ __ ] and went to jail
and came out I think yeah like because
he was like if you get [ __ ] I gotta
have you on or something did you get to
know the people that were doing this to
you I mean would it become like a
routine thing they would always kind of
send different people oh okay you know
like it was weird they would send people
like almost as if like they wanted me to
be like an angry Meathead towards them
too yeah and I thought you're gonna be
like this stupid Meathead yeah
the biggest problem is anytime you have
a government bureaucracy there's no one
to talk to there's really no face
there's no face it's like dealing with
YouTube well everyone just says that's
rental car everyone does that like
people I'm just doing what I'm supposed
to do oh that's my job man it's like
well then who told you to do that's the
problem with government that's the
problem with bureaucracy it's like
there's no accountability man yeah and
and if you cross the board Left Right
politics of course if you let them get a
control of your business dude it's it's
it's a disaster it's a [ __ ] disaster
you have to have some regulation I
understand but I made a buddy I want to
see what branch he's in but he works for
the city and because they were trying to
shut shut down my shows because I was
getting ready for my special during the
start of the pandemic and I need to run
my hours so the haha North Hollywood
stayed open for me yeah so I'd have sold
out shows there twice a week twice a
week for weeks weeks weeks and then that
got noticed because I was blasting all
over social media just like you yeah
we're doing the gym so they try to
shutting it down but then because the
guy was dealing with you and me he's
like listen I support you and Bradley
man he was like they're gonna call me
here he's like I'll make sure and he's
thinking Bradley has any issues I'll
make sure you guys are good like really
he's like I'm gonna treat you good he's
like you won't get shut down
it was stressful it was stressful it was
stressful but it was also cool because
he drew a line in the sand and like I've
never seen a better gym like the
environment the morale like the place
was packed yeah there was time like dude
packed and you're killing it like there
was lines people were waiting that's how
important this [ __ ] was to be here
people were flying all over the country
all over the world coming it's a real
bodybuilder Jim right and a powerlifting
yeah I'd say it's most it's mostly
bodybuilding power looking I'd say that
gym specifically before this new one it
leaned more powerlifting
um but the new gym is probably leading
more bodybuilding surprise I would
imagine most people would tell you just
not to have a bunch of treadmills and
not have that to make money but you
that's what everyone else is doing well
that's what most big big boss he's
different it's all just like treadmills
and put people here because you don't
actually care about you just want them
running on a [ __ ] treadmill right I
have some trembles at the new one I have
more stairs I have more cardio at the
new one just because we have more space
yeah I always wanted that and I never
wanted like the massive lines which I
think is just like you should encourage
people to use all this other stuff
that's a lot more helpful yeah check out
the new gym tomorrow yeah you're gonna
come to the old Zoo I'm gonna come to
the news you will love it beautiful yeah
I'm gonna go around for this if I if I
had five exercises oh no here we go only
five I love it let me let me ask you I'm
gonna I'm gonna say what I think they
were they are and then you tell me okay
deadlift squat bench deadlift squat
bench some kind of a farmer's carry or
some kind of a carrier a load-bearing
exercise you can do a pull-up and then
Pull-Ups
yeah I mean I'd say deadlift and if
we're going with just five yeah I would
say deadlift front squat front squat
Wi-Fi squat just because if we're only
paying five exercises you know and then
I would say
um the farmer the heavy farmer carry is
really good yeah and then I would say
like a clean clean like something more
because you need something kind of
explosive because all the other ones can
be you can do them explosively but if
we're just saying like what's the plan
just up to here or no I mean a clean and
jerk is up to there this is just a clean
is up to here right
um and then the last one will be pull up
yeah if you could only do five and and
but why are you only doing five though
I'm just I'm just always thinking about
what what because he's one of those
people that's like if I could only do
that you know everyone's trying to like
simplify everything but it's really not
that simple but why what else would you
ask no I mean that's that is good but
it's like you could also do a bunch of
others yeah you know because a lot of
people all I'm saying is like most
people start asking questions about
Fitness stuff and they go what's the one
thing I need to do and it's it's just
like no I ask because I like those I
like knowing what the comprehensive like
so the better at question is what are
the essentials so you can do a bunch of
other [ __ ] but you've got to always have
those Squad men's deadlift no matter
what you have to do this yeah yeah
literally everybody yeah and that's and
that's the that's what powerlifting is
that's what powers compete to be good at
those lifts yeah right so obviously I
never did that specifically I mean maybe
not obviously if you wouldn't know me
but I always did like power body
bodybuilding which it's not necessarily
a real thing it's a thing that we've
made it but it's a blend of like I
always kept those a part of my program
and I always tried to push myself
strengthwise but I never tried to like
Max Max PR on them and I always so I
would do that like like for example if I
did chest let's say today's chest I
would go and I would work up to a heavy
set on the bench and then everything
else would be like bodybuilding higher
volume machine this machine that
accessory this accessory that but I
always had those as my like base
foundation so if it was legs I'm doing
heavy squat I work up to something heavy
and then everything else can be volume
so I would always have that like
challenge like volume excuse me
challenge heavy weight maximal as much
as possible and then the rest of the
routine would be but heavyweight doesn't
necessarily build muscle the way
bodybuilding does no way yeah but but
being strong getting stronger through
lifting heavier weight allowing you to
move the other weight more repetitiously
yeah meaning like I could do more volume
with a heavier weight so more volume is
what it tears the muscle down more and
then you build it back up that's
bodybuilding yeah essentially yeah so
it's like imagine it's just because
you're stronger say I'm better at
benching I'm stronger at benching now I
can move the dumbbells you know 150
pounds 20 times instead of two but you
never did that [ __ ] you just did Sports
specific right I did all those [ __ ] man
you did bodybuilding too yeah you always
kind of do all of it but like obviously
Fighters don't it's not it's mostly
probably hip strength and speed
explosiveness like you don't you don't
need to be like this you know yeah
yeah what else current events yep
running all right Corona man sits down
for current events with Bradley Martin
do you always sing nope first time I've
done it great current events with
Bradley Martin let's start off hello
Aaron Donald okay so I mean you a
football guy no I don't really watch
sports too much no Sports just UFC you
are you like balls even you'll see like
you watch over like did you watch this
past weekend wasn't a great card okay
sorry against those games last night no
this past weekend they're dude the last
four weeks all I've been doing is this
gym the games yesterday the wild card
games were fantastic I didn't see a
highlight not one play I was at
Disneyland with my kiddos I saw nothing
some guy in line had his phone out I'm
like dude I I saw your phone are you are
you watching the game yeah what's the
score what's the score I have no I have
no clue but I'm a huge UFC fan yeah you
know Francis left yeah I just saw that
like what is so seriously Jon Jones and
gone are fighting for that Jon Jones
hero gone and then Francis yeah decided
to walk away for good uh I don't think
it's for good as
no I think he wants to do the big boxing
thing no who the [ __ ] is he gonna buy
who's gonna box him Deontay
[ __ ] you money there because you didn't
want to do that she's like cool I'm
gonna do that and then I don't think UFC
thing's done forever I think he can do
that and then come back to the UFC but I
think the UFC is banking on Jon Jones
and Francis is banking on himself I
think Jon Jones in the UFC were like we
think John's gonna beat you so we're not
going to invest all our chips into you
because John's gonna beat you John's
gonna be who you're saying anybody yeah
the UFC bet on John
yes easy oh for sure why
Francis out grappling Zerg off so you
think it's going to be a grappling thing
it's just going to take no I think it's
gonna be a good fight but I think John's
gonna get him down put them how long two
years Time Zero guns much higher level
Striker yeah
uh more powerful but also higher level
right uh not an MMA
more powerful for sure yeah all day what
do you think make John Mike Jones so
great his IQ he he doesn't do anything
like like his striking you're not like
oh we've never seen it his grandpa know
we've never seen it his you know his
cardio we've never seen it I think it's
his mental game is just the best so has
he been trading this whole time oh yeah
and getting big for a heavyweight it's
so weird you see him deadlifting he's
like two six years that's exciting it's
gonna be interesting to see why I can't
wait what it does for Speed and all that
we can get to hold you he's so strong
think about when he gets a hold of you
now and get you down so I think I think
the UFC went all right listen Francis we
don't want you boxing and we don't think
you're gonna be John so here's the money
we're gonna offer you but if you want to
do boxing get the [ __ ] out of there
anyway cool I'm gonna do boxing all
right cool we're gonna bet on John
announce Sarah godfight so your money's
on Sarah on uh John against everybody
yeah I would too on that yeah
yeah I'm excited for that that sounds
[ __ ] amazing it's funny because the
guy at the T-Mobile Arena leaked the
fight without the UFC approval oh really
when will that be it's no it's March 4th
yeah okay I'm canceling my brain I can't
wait he went down I'm getting some bread
dates for companion uh I believe I
really want to go to that fight yeah
yeah that'd be a good one to go to a
John fight's insane I mean it's gonna be
sick yeah and if John beats Cyril gone I
mean it's like like
it's like what but without question the
best of all time these are already but I
mean that seals the only other arguments
could be but he didn't do it long enough
imagine he comes in there and just does
it decisively but think about it it
starts in 30 seconds well bro UFC's a
hole it might be and then Francis beats
so then UFC looks really bad no but it's
it's possible Cyril gone you know look
he's when John gets hit his last few
fights he's gotten hit yeah and Cyril
gone is a high level kickboxer I mean
he's he he's he's a big problem for John
because his footwork is athletic
abilities but he can't grapple it's a
huge issue he can't grapple big factor
yeah because as soon as that guy can he
stop the takedown no absolutely as soon
as he got on him it was done
John's a different animal so we'll see
his wrestling how do we what was the
what was your uh thing what was the
current event Aaron Donald how do we go
for mayor Donald dude no no I was just
looking through the current events and
then that one we were talking about
sports oh gotcha yeah yeah okay you said
your balls even UFC yeah you don't watch
any other sports you got into football
I think Super Bowl is bills Niners
Niners are gonna mean as [ __ ] him but I
gotta watch it then that's probably the
smartest are you serious Bill's Niners
well no no Philly Philly KC or Philly
Bill 100 the the Niners no one's better
the last time but the Niners look so
good they keep winning they've won like
what 10 in a row well since they got
Christian McCaffrey and the Purdy's I
believe the last time the Niners was
good was back when Kaepernick was
playing for them right yes okay Harbaugh
was the coach I think you have to look
at like like who's injured and who's the
freshest like whatever whatever it is it
feels like it remembers the Niners were
injured all season because Nick boso is
the best defense play in the league
right uh Debo Samuel was injured and
then they signed Chris McCaffrey then uh
Garoppolo got hurt Trey Lance got hurt
so then this that's what I mean so now
they've played less games they're not as
bad as basically I mean he's better than
Trent delpher was but he basically came
in and they're third all those weapons
you just need somebody to manage and
give them the ball that's why I'm saying
because they look so fresh they look so
fresh when you see a team that's been
playing 16 games and they're beating up
and their offensive line is slower and
beating up they're dealing with injuries
you have guys who were injured in the
beginning of the season now they're
healthy they played less games and it
just feels like they're just they're
just playing all about timing like yeah
being healthy now the now now the Eagles
100 with with hurt Jalen hurts I mean
that's but he's been out for three weeks
I don't know what's going on here though
so Aaron Donald
what is it yes I don't know much about
this saw this pop up but I guess Aaron
Donald tweeted something I love Twitter
Twitter by the way is my favorite
[ __ ] platform to use the Twitter
former
a Pittsburgh football player number 97
whatever
and then drop the former afterwards I
guess he tweeted that he was former well
the former pit football player though
hold on he changed his bio to say former
NFL d-linemen for the Rams number
hashtag 99 and then he's there was rumor
he was gonna retire yeah so he put that
in his bio and then took it out real
quick
huh so he said he was on the team retire
because there's been speculation I was
going to retire
former pit football player NFL d-liner
for the Rams maybe he just [ __ ]
typoed that [ __ ]
well that that that uh profile picture
is very uh Herschel Walker's son-ish
we're going back there a little bit a
little thicker than uh than his son a
little thicker
Aaron Donald I think is God Bradley
Martin's strength he's got that off the
chart [ __ ] yeah he's strong and very
strong man so people were into frenzy
apparently thinking he's gonna yeah who
sees this [ __ ] like that that fact like
how long do you want I mean social media
[ __ ] profile all day yeah he just
changed it I saw it who gives a [ __ ]
dude
let's go
Trevor Lawrence hold on oh wait so okay
you guys just wait and he's like wait go
ahead what's that sorry just you said
wait it says wait you just threw me off
oh okay I'm sorry so Skrillex we all
know Skrillex right we've all seen him
so he apparently he changed his look
recently and this is how we all
recognize him right yes right with that
sometimes he has to shave side on the
yeah on one side so this is how it looks
now
yeah that's him
how did he get a beard you just screw it
up sounds like you had a dialysis no I
guess he just grew it out
wait wait but his eye like go down
uh-huh
I know it doesn't even look like him at
all kind of seeing similarities you can
kind of see similarities here that's him
what are you based on no it's trying to
go ahead no I want your really good no
no no hold on wait what do you saying
that's him I'm the face expert you're
the man face expert go ahead as the man
how did he get a dog how do you get
please Parker and Latino no it's for
real it doesn't look like go ahead tell
us how you know that's him guys you've
got to look at the eyes look at the ears
he's wearing glasses so you can't see
what you can't see his eyebrows are okay
you're right about the nose for sure and
you see he's got the jawline I'm happy
with the jawline
and uh okay so this is the first place
Idaho killer with a glass well he looks
he looks different dude I he looks like
a completely different person yes he
does he looks very strong he might be he
might be loud
or something Skrillex could be a lot of
things
now what's his Heritage maybe Armenian
maybe Latin Skrillex ethnicity
there you go alien let's see
English descent Spanish there you go
[ __ ] I told you well then what
happened earlier huh I don't know bro I
was born in L.A yep birth name it says
likely yes honey oh likely likely yeah
so we don't know
Sunny John wait it was that Skrillex was
adopted so we have no clue it's named uh
Sunny Moore
Sunny John Moore all right
damn yeah completely different yeah good
for him I'm getting my [ __ ] new look
I know where I'm going to looks like you
just went to Drake stylist it was like I
need to find that stylist yeah
totally different bro I'm all about it
it really leveled up damn congrats this
is what would happen if I went to a
status I'd go what can you do and The
Stylist would go
can you make this happen yeah they go
they go how much are we getting I mean
you're 55 yeah it's like you really is
this really important right now yeah
just leave yourself alone and the
assistant goes well he could grow out
his hair he go just drink more water
this one
yeah this this popped up on my feed and
I just wanted I just wanted the behind
the scenes scoop because what is this he
almost murdered this poor style okay
who's tiny first of all
Sonny does the Pod uh with us on full
sound and does he work with you or he
works with uh he worked with Steve we'll
do it he used to be civil do its
assistant okay and then
um he started filming content with me
because like I was always around filming
content with Steve like me and Steve for
some content and because he's Steve
assistant he's always there and then he
kind of became a character in some of my
videos and then people like kind of were
like oh this shit's funny and then
um he got the opportunity to go work and
do the podcast and he tried to do both
and that's why him and Steve have a
little bit of beef because I think Steve
felt a little bit like I don't know kind
of hurt that you know he dipped and kind
of like started working you know not not
alongside him anymore and he kind of
like he's kind of like yo I brought you
to the party and I just bitched me yeah
yeah and then and then Steve on this so
far yeah and then so then he wanted to
to do the podcast which everybody wants
to be famous because he feels like
there's more for his career like
longevity or whatever but also from uh
his perspective he's probably telling
Steve hey dude do you think I came down
LA to be an assistant all my life so
that's what it is right hit it what is
this
this is fiery you know what this is he
it seems like he had an issue with uh
your tape podcast first of all yeah it
was absolutely but I do want to point
out one thing you did have your plan of
y'all I'm gonna be a gangster I'm gonna
call this guy out you didn't want to do
that you actually got on your hands and
knees and sucked this guy's dick for an
hour and a half okay now I'm gonna
disrespect you
[ __ ] Cherry little [ __ ] rat who
says that yeah but I don't like the way
he's talking to Bradley it's okay so say
it again let me rephrase it say what I
what I do in my hands and knees okay
okay I'll smack you okay take it back
I'm gonna send back your thousand too
take it send me that thousand dollars
back too by the way [ __ ] I'll smack the
[ __ ] out of you by the way Bradley
Bradley I love that you did that here's
what guys like that have to understand
don't block us guys like that have to
understand you can't just talk to
another dude like that without
permission yeah you will take him and
break fold them like a chair here's the
deal with steiny steiny is the kind of
guy who he I love steiny okay I want a
preferences by saying I love Simon he's
a friend of mine but okay but steiny
will
it's like bro like you can't throw shade
because like half the time I give him
shits because he's already throwing [ __ ]
well they're just before guys before him
we go oh you got in your hands and knees
and sucked entertainment yeah it's like
bro what all that happened was was that
Andrew was like we were waiting there
for maybe an hour
and I was like making jokes like we just
got like a [ __ ] rapper like not
showing up we're here like we knew we
were supposed to be here he was coming
back from some [ __ ] did you film it up
at his house in Dubai okay so we're at
his house and we're set up and we're
chilling there for a while we're just
like joking banter on a podcast and um
my plan was like yo when he comes here I
was like I was like I'm gonna ask him
why the [ __ ] he took so long and then he
was like oh you won't ask him that and
the reason why I didn't ask him that is
because as soon as he shows up we're
getting into like some conversation
because steiny right away goes he gives
him like a a
um what's a cigar and the conversation
goes right into the cigar you're gonna
stop him but hold on exactly why are you
late then the whole
exactly did you go into the interview
not liking Andrew no no not at all not
at all I was just saying like we were
just okay prior to this we had driven
around like we were like no sleep for
like hours this is like why like
well the next because the way we're
doing content is like non-stop so the
day before we like non-stop like I think
we flew in we go to a pod we did like
four pots we did pause all these
Fighters we sat in a room and like the
fighters kept coming in and then it's
super [ __ ] late then we get it the
next day yeah I was wearing UFC Abu
Dhabi and we so there's very little
sleep so at this point this is like
after three days of podcast Non-Stop and
traveling around back and forth between
places that are hours two hours away
going from Abu Dhabi to buy back and
forth all this [ __ ] we're all on like no
sleep so we show up there by the way
Scotty's on a bunch of Adderall which is
why he tweaked down that interview and
he started acting crazy oh so that was
there that was there it was hilarious so
there's other moments in interview where
I'm like steiny shut the [ __ ] up and
like literally questions he's asking
take questions and tastes like are we
gonna do this like you're asking me dumb
ass [ __ ] like you ask me some [ __ ] that
matters and even I'm gonna tell him sign
him like Sonny shut the [ __ ] up and I'll
try and ask some questions and it kind
of looks like I'm mean to him but it's
like he was tweaking yeah where it's
like yo relax I just like that you're
you you said I'll snatch you out of that
chair yeah but it's like
I never really heard them but it's like
it's just a but you could yeah it's just
it's just like I never come in being
like I'm gonna [ __ ] on well I remember
with Brendan there was a there he had an
altercation with a certain fighter and
and they called the guy called Brendan
his coach called Brendan and said hey uh
don't you don't have anything to worry
about and the Fighter's much smaller
than Brandon and Brennan was like what
what do you mean by I don't have
anything to worry about he goes he's not
gonna fight you nobody's gonna you know
come at you and he goes Brennan goes hey
dude you didn't think I was actually
afraid physically of your boy did you
because I'll come down there and lock
the door and find everybody there don't
forget I'm a heavyweight you [ __ ]
dumb you want to pull the tiger yeah
don't be [ __ ] don't [ __ ] around I'm
sorry what yeah yeah like don't don't do
that it's just it's a lot of that in
your face for this stuff it's just part
of the banter part of like the way the
Comedy Works but I just want to say like
I'm never coming out and being like I'm
gonna [ __ ] on signing it's just I've
always feel like he comes out and he has
this like I don't know yeah where he
wants to do it he's a good guy huh
there's a rat energy he comes in he
wants to throw and then I'm like wait
okay now I have to it's like overall
he's a good guy yeah he's a good guy you
want to kill him but whatever uh you
know he [ __ ] Steve but yeah he screwed
over Steve sorry you didn't screw him
over he wanted more for him so I'm
standing on this side like I'd tell
Steve like why why are you hating on me
like you think I want to be in the
system all my life like I'm trying to
work but so the problem was it's not
even so much it was just he could have
done it a different way I don't know how
he did it I'm just saying overall like
he could have communicated it better it
was just kind of like that it's awkward
I'm sure yeah it's probably time now
your your interview with Andrew Tate
what's your takeaway with Andrew Tate
um so we did that interview we talked
about a lot of important [ __ ] and the
thing that I was really trying to talk
to him about was like obviously you know
everyone talks to him about like this
misogynistic [ __ ] they talk about all
this stuff and uh I was more so trying
to get to him to
open up to his ideas about
um kind of like you know mental health
in in the importance of like going after
that for men and he does really believe
and he does really care seemingly like
having this conversation with him on
camera and I don't know exists I know
there's clips of it floating around the
internet because it was taken off of
YouTube but it's reposted it it's
probably somewhere why this is taking
off YouTube oh I don't know but not even
because there's some there's a ton it
exists but anyways it's floating around
somewhere but I had a conversation that
conversation with him the podcast was
great I think it was it was a really
like good podcast and then I talked to
him for like about three hours after
like No cameras nothing we're just
sitting at a table talking and uh dude
yeah he's a good dude and see the thing
is like you know I hear these
allegations and stuff people say I don't
know
um the truth behind it all uh I can't
speak on that but there could you though
that's right I don't know him that well
no yeah no and the thing is though the
at the core like
it didn't feel I didn't feel like
because I could normally spend some time
with someone spent like three hours
talking to someone you're gonna know uh
this guy's kind of they're just kind of
scummy right yeah there was nothing he
said that was like oh he's just scummy
like everything of the conversation we
were have was just like was actually
about the world and as it sits and how
it is and I think a lot of his messaging
is good but it's over kind of the the
negative stuff overshadows all the good
stuff he's doing well I don't know if it
was just some wild [ __ ] and then they
just the media runs with that that's
what it is I don't think it's
overshadows with it I think it's just a
shadow because the media yes yeah
because they want it's like they want
they do want that now like I guess for
whatever their reasons are like
it's just a weird thing because from my
perspective looking at it as he just
garnered so much popularity so fast and
had such a massive like he got on
Twitter after he after he was kicked off
all the platforms he got on Twitter in
like two days he had two million
followers yeah yeah he has almost five
million followers there's a whole
movement like the sigma movement among
these young men who uh basically follow
him but they but if you actually look at
a lot of the movement it looks very
positive it's like you know work out be
healthy be a high value male read the
right thing so a lot of his message
feels yeah like it's it's very positive
and then you have the whole other thing
that's like touted as like he's a
misogynistic pig that's what they do
though but so so they're one of these
label him these writers these writers
who already have made up their mind will
say misogynistic you know uh influencer
and that's how you get branded and so
they just put a label on you right away
and a lot of it was just theatrics so I
don't know I haven't listened to enough
of him yeah I mean there's there's
always more to this well like his take
on Teslas
what the [ __ ] man he's in the same line
as I am what the [ __ ] it's pretty funny
honestly his Tesla it's hilarious but
here's the thing about Tate two I think
people who can't understand hopefully
like not all of it is straight to he's
somewhat of just a [ __ ] comedian like
he's comedy like a lot of it
entertainment yeah and that's the thing
like people but then I get it because
like they just they they get a bit of
information they go oh I didn't like
that they get a little more they go I
like this and then certain people they
just decide and they he said they're
deciding off one clip absolutely if you
watch One Clip you're like some because
when I first learned about it someone
sent me some of his Clips like Jesus
check this out check this out you see
the clip like oh my God that's insane
but then it's like that's from a long
form check this out go to uh go to do
you have tick tock on here we can get it
yeah pull up my tick tock
so I just wanted to give you guys uh
perfect example of clip clip like
behavior and people reaction to right
um so on my Tick Tock what the [ __ ] is
that
it just jumps away I mean what are you
watching over there no it's just jumped
off so you go to his Tick Tock gym yeah
so
I'll just explain this you just pull the
first video up I stopped posting on Tick
Tock for a while but pull that first
video up yeah click that you know we
don't got to go into detail but so a
bunch of people are making videos about
this at the new gym okay so uh 2023 I
just decided this year I was like you
know what yeah I'm done with people
running my name for cloud previews
um slander it's out of control I get it
you guys want to [ __ ] good views on
Tick Tock congrats you got some you
gotta reply but I want to make this
clear
the day as it went there were probably
thousands of people wrapped out wrapped
outside of this building right here
door's actually broken by the way the
entire event was free what happened was
there was a mouth explain this I don't
know maybe a thousand people in here 500
people in here what we were trying to do
was get people out who had been there
for hours to leave through the back of
the gym we tried multiple times before
the cook that you see
to get them to leave we're yelling blah
blah we didn't have a speaker we
eventually got a speaker more of the
story is this there are people waiting
outside in the rain for hours and hours
and hours we were basically trying to
move in while we were trying to move
people out
um and only thing I was saying about the
influencers was the people that I
invited I didn't want them to leave
because I was saying everyone leave I
wanted them to stay because a lot of
people who came to this event came to
see some of those influences and the
point was to have them stay and the
people who were coming to visit the gym
who have been there for an hour and a
half two hours to leave to allow other
people to come into the gym to
experience the gym so you just deal with
all the hate and the [ __ ] so yeah so
let me explain so there's a clip of me
that someone because like there's a
bunch of people filming as I'm up there
talking and I'm saying everyone get out
if you're not an influencer get out and
what that meant was I invited like 50
influences to show up to promote the
event to be at the event right so people
get this clip saying if you're not
influencer get the [ __ ] out and it's
like Brad's a bad guy look at this I
can't believe this but if you're there
and you realize because like even a clip
will use that that said that was I cut
before you see everything else that
comes before so that's the part of the
internet that like you can't avoid what
I was doing was we did yeah yes we
didn't have it as planned as we should
have for sure right the gym was also
done in five weeks everything was rushed
I didn't sleep for [ __ ] like four
days leading up to that I did the best I
could right but what I was trying to do
was move the people who had been in
there for an hour and a half two hours
out to get more people in because there
was so many people waiting in the rain
and so I said if you're not influenced
to get out so they cut it they spin it
they go he's so he doesn't care about
regular people oh my God reminded me of
a problem and like like it takes so much
to do this stop it takes so much to
build a gym it takes so much to build a
business take so much to promote a
business take so much to keep it going
like you've been doing like you said
you've been working your ass off your
whole life and I feel like now with the
uh journalist that's motivated that just
doesn't like you for whatever reason or
just personally just people online they
can do with their highly motivated they
can just cause destruction and it's just
so easy for them it's just so easy yeah
and it's just just it that's a major
problem because it's like dude I'm
trying the best I can I'm working it's
so hard to be successful and you mostly
fail and so when you get a success it's
just so maddening that we live in a
world where it's just so easy to be like
bam it's also a waste of the time though
the people doing that it's like okay you
know Zoo keeps going you know people
membership it's fun it's fun for people
today if you can find a community of
trolls or haters as well everybody wants
this is my thing this is the thing that
frustrates me is like people treat
everyone as if like they're [ __ ]
perfect and it's like I didn't do
everything perfect no all I was trying
to do was like make a situation better
for everyone else who was outside who
also wanted to come in right and then I
get people on the internet who are never
there who take a clip and go oh my God I
can't believe this is so bad it's like
you don't have any understanding
actually of the event and you tell me I
know who you are yeah and you just have
a you just have so everyone there who
came to the vet knows yeah but but on
the internet they're going to spin and
say Brad doesn't care about regular
people because he said influencers stay
and it's like yeah that's what we're all
trying but it's like all I should have
said the people that I invited every one
of you stay and everyone else has to
leave regardless if I said that or not
no one wanted to leave it just took time
to get people out of there so then
you're dealing because we did it like
three times before I got up there and
said everyone get the [ __ ] out and no
one was listening and so it was just
kind of like it got frustrating because
then I see this and it's like wow you
guys like all that work gets it's like
lumped into now just people wanting to
get views because they could say look
what a bad guy this is based off
negativity on the internet because if
they post look what a good guy is it's
not gonna get exactly that's that's the
ruined Brad so we're talking about tape
we're gonna go we're just gonna talk
about the bad things and label the bad
things so we can make these things that
are these big statements and everyone's
like oh my God but if you're a
journalist you make your name that way
it's really hard as a journalist to make
money number one number two you've got
to do so much and when there is a way to
spin something in a negative light if
you can if you can get that headline you
get clicks so there's so much pressure
that's the problem with the algorithm on
social media but the problem with with
the media with this you know a website
the problem with YouTube the problem
with social media is negativity gets
pushed in the algorithm not positive
well that's because it's getting people
to to discuss right but here's the crazy
thing now is like
that so after I did this I responded I
never respond to [ __ ] yeah I responded
to it 10 times the amount of videos
people are making being like dude look
at this so it's like even you try to be
like Hey listen to this everyone's still
like oh I can make a video and talk bad
about Bradley Martin get views oh I'm
doing it now I'd say a great day right
if that's the case though yeah but it's
just like [ __ ] it's like yo you guys
are [ __ ] lame because they're trying
to make you look bad yeah so that they
look good so that they give you so that
they make money it's a very special but
I'm a bad guy bro what the [ __ ] it's
such a strange phenomenon like it really
makes you look at humanity and there's
something about you all of us though
some of that in all of us that we're all
all of us have all of these things I
disagree I don't think we're all [ __ ]
well no if you're trying to make a video
of I know but what I'm saying is if
you're trying to be the best you can be
as a human being like you're trying to
be good at something which is so [ __ ]
hard it's so hard to be good at anything
like it just takes so much that you
don't have time for that like you just
what actually happens when you're if
you're young and just please listen to
this if you're trying to be good or you
want a good life
if you are living your life in a
critical way if you're actually being
critical even in your own mind it gets
in the way of everything positive that
you could have the goodies don't lie in
being a Critic the goodies lie in trying
to see the good in things and being
better yourself and that is that is what
something I wish I could I could have
told myself when I was younger I was
never that negative but there are a lot
of people that do that that don't
understand that and it doesn't do you
any good it just doesn't see but I don't
think it's fair to say that to everybody
no I mean I mean we all have Sinners and
Saints and we're we're bipolar rapes we
have we have the angels of our lesser
nature and the angels of our better
nature and your job is to let the angels
of your better nature take you over
completely as you get older that's what
I'm trying to say so I don't know it's
frustrating man not bad but if I don't
peace soon I'm gonna die you guys go
then you're no I would love it uh give
us one more there's just like the KSI
fight that uh oh you guys both know
Logan Paul and Jake Paul and stuff so uh
Jake Paul and Logan Paul out Jake but
then he was like I need a few more
warm-ups right well I gotta say this
everyone he's beat now is was not I
don't want to say they're lame but like
he would knock them out right away he
beat another Boxer guy he beat this guy
like like no one has spent as much time
doing this as Jake Paul
so as far as he's but I liked how he's
aware he's like I'm not ready for Jake
yet yeah he said I need a few more if I
get to Jake Paul it's like yeah I mean I
think you see what I'm saying like he
just that's it you know like that was
the fight first round I think it's funny
how Jake Paul's Logan is like in cahoots
with him with that Prime energy drink or
whatever it is so he's like hyping up
KSI and Jake's right next to him yeah I
don't it's an interesting Dynamic but I
mean it's the internet It's
Entertainment it is what it is I I
really do think though Jake has [ __ ]
I think he's like serious taking this
[ __ ] really oh yeah Jake sleeps KSI and
I think so a minute right now yeah
KSI because so I did a video years ago
where KSI punched me in the face I
didn't feel Logan punched me in the face
case I did hit really hard years ago
really I'm sure he's probably way harder
that was a good knocking they're
wonderful not gonna lie though I like
ksi's moving I agree very very Crotty
blitzes like he just blitzed the dude
bam
even at that level is impressive but
he's not he's pronounced cut up he's
nowhere near Jake Paul's no I'm saying I
hate when he's nowhere nearing Jake
Paul's atmosphere he's got his boxing
goes that was a good karate Blitz but
that that's that fight is gonna sell the
most numbers you mean KSI KSI Jake Paul
easily people don't realize how massive
ksr no like KSI is he insanely Bigger
Than Jake and Logan what yeah he is he's
huge sold out O2 Arena huge he's massive
he's a what I don't even know what he
does YouTuber gamer turned boxers
a lot of reacts videos shits content is
good he's he's huge makes all the money
in the world yes crushes massive good
for him
young kids man bro that that that fight
is going to do
uh yeah um hey before we go the Logan
Paul crypto thing
I mean bro I I just see I've just seen
all the [ __ ] I've seen the coffee Zilla
stuff
um I think it was interesting because he
had to
he removed some videos like he he said
some stuff and everyone was mad that
like he didn't uh not in not admit to it
but he was like his apology video was
blaming everyone else that he's taking
the ownership no ownership yeah right
and that's why they that's why they were
like yeah Logan didn't take ownership
and I can kind of understand like I'm a
fraction of the success that Logan is
but I get into business ventures where I
really don't have anything to do with it
there's a lot of other fun Bros so when
it blows up and people and then you're
not going to sue the no-name guy they
come for you and you're like whoa hold
on bro I dealt with nothing to do with
it hold on like I can't I can't fault
Logan like 100 on this because I I dealt
with something similar where I got
[ __ ] finesse in the same space and I
had to [ __ ] threaten to sue these
guys who were basically robbing this
project and to get the money back into
the project to then you know try to
gracefully as I could and you don't know
much about it yeah but so I'm thinking
about it I I spent I did spend time with
the guys I did like they convinced me
the best that they could yeah and they
[ __ ] got me who took down the videos
so so Logan Paul made two responses uh
one on his main show and then one on
impulsive I don't know if you took down
the impulsive episode but I know that he
took down the the response that was like
Hey all this stuff happened but these
were criminals that I hired it's it's
kind of it seemed like it's kind of
their fault
um and there was no real apology and
then I think you're taking the ownership
further yeah and I think they kind of
were like yo what the [ __ ] everyone's so
like yo [ __ ] you and then like another
one and then he did the I think prior to
that the Christianity stuff that he was
knocking George foreign
all this [ __ ] like in the last couple
weeks for him that was just like Dutch
everything was like trying to shoot even
the pig things people were coming for me
he's like hold on I love I gave that pig
to this fan family think they're going
to take it yeah I don't listen but
that's what but I told Logan Paul I was
talking to him the other day about it
it's like dude you you're not going to
win over certain people it's just not
going to happen so any little [ __ ] in
the armor that they can see a crack in
they're gonna go for like like the dog
that I used to have people like oh you
got rid of the dog you gave away a dog
or killed the dog no it's not no I
didn't do any of that [ __ ] that's not
what the dog was a show dog and the guy
goes oh you're not going to use it I go
no and it wasn't fitting with the family
so he goes here's what we're gonna do
I'm gonna use it this dog tank as a show
dog why don't I take the dog back
because it's a show dog and you're not
gonna use it for a show and then what of
the new litter what's in your new dog
yeah say less because you knew you said
you weren't going to show them no and
the dog is a legit show dog yeah that
makes sense just send me another one
that's not show dog and I don't have to
pay the premium he goes yeah say less he
picks up the dog the dog's trained to be
a show dog now with its mom and dad
because the mom and dad of show dogs the
internet's like oh you got rid of this
dog you killed the dog like no no no wow
same thing same [ __ ] I just discussed
about my gym it's like they just take it
so I I definitely have feel for for what
Logan ball is experiencing because like
you you're never gonna always get it
right you know that's the thing that's
the thing that the overarching thing
that bothers me about this whole like
Internet space is that like I said
everyone tries to treat these
influencers and people that they see as
like you should be [ __ ] perfect and
it's like straight on you guys are
exactly no mistakes so that's the
problem that's the thing that I don't
like is it's like this like this uh I
don't know what the word is but it's
like when you try to make someone be bad
because oh you're bad but it's like
you're like what about you like for you
to just [ __ ] on someone else just
because you can I get it it's the
internet you want to do it it's Twitter
you want to do it fine but like I don't
know it just it feels like it just
encouraging people just like to just
attack other people and never look and I
don't know if that's ever gonna stop but
when I told Logan that this is my motto
and all this thing [ __ ] everybody you
you do it for the people that ride with
you those that don't don't worry about
pleasing them you don't need to answer
to them you just keep doing you yeah
those people that ride with you are
going to [ __ ] those that don't you're
never gonna win over yeah so don't
bother at I'm gonna be honest I didn't
like the the Christianity thing but I'm
not even Christian about the [ __ ] out I
don't know what was going on with the
Christianity I didn't really well it was
like it was like George was buddy got
religious right well his buddy is very
religious and I've I mean I've had
plenty of conversations with him too but
it was a great guy it wasn't uh it was
just the way he went about it and he
apologized in a later episode it was
just kind of like he he was basically
saying like you're crazy if you believe
in this like you need a therapist and
it's like this is my thing and white
people probably got so upset I mean
obviously this I can't say why everyone
got upset but I was like that's kind of
[ __ ] just because someone's
relationship with with uh God or with a
God or with religion is like a very
personal intimate relationship and for
you to tell someone that it's not okay
it's what it is I feel like Logan knows
better but that's what I'm saying so
that's why I didn't get it but he did
Apologize he did come back and talk
about feeling under siege and sometimes
in that situation you're going to say a
lot of [ __ ] when you're making a video I
would imagine yeah I mean I don't know
okay yeah is this is this uh nft debacle
over now or so I don't know so he
released something recent that I didn't
see he was running like a blue hoodie
can we pull that up it's on his Twitter
I think I didn't get to see this but
basically he was saying something else
about I think he's trying to make it
right I think he's trying to make it
right he's trying to give money back
which is which is fair he he was it
before the fight yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah I didn't watch this yet hold him I
apologize
coffeezilla is not a criminal I called
him I apologize my initial response to
his series was that of of a fire uh an
ego flare whatever it is pride I'm a
fighter at heart and I was Defensive
because I know I never scammed anyone
with this project I never made any money
never sold any tokens and I only had the
best intentions going in
um but the fact is the suing coffee
Zilla is not going to help crypto Zoo
holders so I do need to focus my
attention where it should be which is on
fans and supporters of me
so I'd like to announce my three-step
plan moving forward step one Jeff and I
are going to burn our Zoo tokens so we
have no Financial upside in the game and
it will add value to hold their tokens
step two uh we want to offer a Rewards
program for players who are disappointed
in the status of the game so essentially
you're going to be yeah pause it pause
it because it's not so but he's trying
to apologize I already like him so but
here so here's the thing this is why
people go they go like they're on
unforgiving because they go well you're
doing this now because this guy exposes
no he's making it right yeah I mean
that's fair it's fair but a lot of
people are like you're doing it now
because you're like but those people you
can never win over that's my thing with
Logan do what you think's right in your
heart stay on the path those people that
are like oh this isn't good enough [ __ ]
it but my thing is
selling tokens are making any money on
the tokens all right so that that's
significant to me like he didn't if he
made a ton of money on the on the on
this deal but be what he's saying people
even with this they're like the only
reason you're doing this because this is
like this is time later this isn't like
it just happened last week now he's
talking about it okay this is like this
was a long time ago and then coffee
still have made a bunch of videos late
like a year later you do not want that
coffee still on your trip yeah I try to
get him on my pod I want to be talking
to him he's thorough but he's like I
don't really do a podcast that guy's
amazing he's so good [ __ ] incredible
I don't even know what they're talking
about I was in yeah why I listened to it
I text Logan dude you and this good boy
stuff makes you feel old I don't know
what the [ __ ] going on here I said but
this coffee still is damn good he's
great so that's the thing it's like I
it's it's just they go people go because
it's a year later all this is happening
now because coffee forced you to respond
so people think if if he didn't do this
you would have never done this yeah so
that's why people feel like the I think
I think anybody who knows Logan I know
enough people like you guys know him and
I've only met him once everybody says
good things but this is the other thing
about Jake or Logan Paul you know how
many other business ventures he has
going on a lot so it's like you have so
much I don't know at my level how much
I've got to take him he has so much [ __ ]
going on you're crazy if you think he
had this crazy elaborate plan to screw
everybody over you know how much money
this kid has yeah he's damn we're close
to being a billionaire yeah you think he
gives a [ __ ] about this crypto stuff you
think he needs to figure out a way to
screw people over with it feels like
yeah even from the coffee Zilla guy that
he got involved with some people who
really know this stuff yep and we'd like
to announce our engagement this is his I
love how we keep going back to this yeah
like like it would make the news yeah I
got a P2 uh I'm gonna be doing
bodybuilding Tampa this weekend Friday
Saturday I'm not bodybuilding jokes on
stage I will be in a thong Tampa put two
shows Friday two shows Saturday Tampa
Florida I'm in Springfield Missouri
February 3rd through the 4th Naples
Florida back in Florida hell yeah
February 16th through the 18th
Bakersfield one night only that [ __ ]
almost sold out so come on get your
tickets Bakersfield California one night
only February 23rd Brea March 3rd and
4th I'm gonna have to reschedule because
I have a fight companion on third and
fourth uh so we'll reschedule Brea and
then Oklahoma City's March 9th through
the 11th get your tickets at
thickboy.com or fatkz.com we have new
thick boy merch dropping soon and then
if you want that award-winning thick
nectar go to thickboy.com get you some
we just restocked so get you some Daniel
part of Daniel improv this weekend
Thursday Friday Saturday I'll see you
there Edmonton Canada the comic strip
haven't been back in four years February
2012. I'll be ready then I got Nashville
Tennessee March two three and four
you'll be ready
go to the new gym yeah pull up my uh
comedian schedule just kidding what no
uh can you can yeah I'm gonna be at the
gym all week I'm coming tomorrow come
Gabe everyone's invited if you guys want
to come by I'm buying a sleeper casinos
new culture Encino not the one off
DeSoto and Woodland Hills it's Encino
the new gym the new address is on the on
the uh it's new address is 16571 Ventura
Boulevard
and if you if you watch this I'm gonna
honor this I'll let you in for free if
you mention uh the fighter indicator
yeah baby straight up yeah I'm gonna
mention it tomorrow yeah I love you
brother yes keep crushing it always
thank you guys are dope blocked what the
[ __ ] stop blocking us